jeanine cette ville depuis son ouverture
le club du vieux colombier a déjà une
petite histoire qu'elle est elle cette
histoire en 1948
nous sommes aperçus enfin je me suis
aperçu dirigeants le club de théâtre du
vieux-colombier de vingt quatre ans que
j ai perdu bien qu ayant créé des pièces
très importantes comme huis clos de jean
paul sartre pour les comme la pièce de
marcel aymé la première case et marcel
aymé lucien débouchés et bien d'autres
que j perdait beaucoup large enfants
alors je me suis dis hein je vais mieux
je ne peux pas continuer je vais
mouiller il faut que je trouve un moyen
de gagner de l'argent assure m'arrivait
laroque de saint-germain-des-prés joxi
y'a bien sûr que j'avais où je souhaite
aussi déjà vu des cas égard les caps
plein de rage avant cette horrible chose
que nous avons nettoyé et donc le club
du oui j'ai dit pourquoi ne pas utiliser
les quarts enfin c'était l'organisation
scientifique du travail parce que cela
m'a alors vous avez ouvert le club du
vieux colombes avec alain soral ou le
samedi d'en bas va faire une boîte de
nuit comme les autres il faut trouver
quelque chose de nouveau quelque chose
de valeur et on a découvert avec un tout
petit peu de retard puisqu'il avait déjà
eu deux bris de le premier bris du jazz
de 1948
claude lutter de m'engager critères qui
a amené avec lui toute la grande vente
de saint germain des prés de cette
époque c'est à dire je devrais coen
michael a dit pas qu'elle disparaisse
bien et cetera j'en oublie certainement
et je m'en excuse auprès d'eux et puis
le club du vieux colombier a bien
démarré nous avons fait d'ennemis
mémorable dans j'espère que la presse un
tiers et tout ce qui selon lui à
l'époque se souvient on se souvient go
est lui bien sûr et puis elle nous
arrivons à ce soir saint germain des
prés a vu la fortune qu'il a eu un
certain moment de l'avant commencé à
glisser avec tout saint germain des près
et puis nous sommes dit ben voilà on va
recommencer on va relancer quelque chose
on a refait absolument complètement la
maison pillée oui elle est très curieuse
évidemment c'est ce qui frappe de
l'entrée lycée on voit les bureaux
absolument couvert d'écaillés d'huîtres
vient nous avons pillé en vérité les
écailles et de 300 représentants par
deux femmes un joueur eh bien oui il ya
environ trente camionnettes pleines
stagiaires 500 milles 8 coquilles 8 en
vérité que nous avons mis sur les murs
et puis nous avons aussi ses matches des
matches et trois largeurs bana qui sont
très beaux et sont très étranges et puis
nous nous sommes dit eh bien nous allons
reprendre les vrais grands piliers du
jazz à saint-germain-des-prés
c'est à dire que l'idéal est toujours à
la maison et puis c'est d'aimer
championnat l'entente qui devait des
bourgeois députée dans quelques jours
plus je dis exactement un bien si on
peut le dire a entendu parler de la rue
de la rentrée de sydney ici et il a aidé
les prix par le feu sacré il a dit moi
je veux absolument venir assister à sa
rentrée le club du vieux colombier et je
fais une gemme s'échine avec lui avec le
bus ter et avec tous ces musiciens et je
sois je crois que la maison sera
vraiment le temps voulu at il y aura
naturellement être lutter les danseurs
ou bob sont vraiment extraordinaires qui
sont merveilleuses garçons d'excellents
danseurs
les filles aussi d'ailleurs
il n'y aura pas de ses doigts ce qu est
un chanteur américain que tout paris je
crois venait maintenant passer très très
longtemps ici sidney bechet
naturellement et là enfin c'est une
rencontre exceptionnelle ce sens on va
lui demander à sydney béchet on va lui
demander ce qu'il pense de cette
rencontre
anton se dépêcher on vous savez monsieur
se met toujours plaisir avec mon ami
dans moi est très beau duchesnay alors
écouter johnny de cette ville m'a dit
que ce soir en plus d'une rencontre
c'était aussi une rencontre des styles
de jazz qu'est ce que vous pensez dans
qu'on destine de jason à ses plus hauts
annuels
oui ça peut nous envoyer moi je dis oui
on a mais messieurs raptor où ils jouent
tous d'esprit
tout décider le dr
biba modem des médias que nous vendions
tu peux nous dire quelques mots lui
voulez vous lui demandez de toute l
afrique et middle with you less than
life belgium madoff
ces déchets en mer dont moi je soutienne
show was great aux jo quand il dit
janine civils qui auraient été destinées
il a dit que de toute façon
cet été sont grandes à eagles et de mal
une plaisait il est y jouait jeudi à les
dire j'en faisais parce que la cause de
flash ball il joue le tout des soeurs de
jazz et que 60 pour la joie le site ne
chute que j'irai n'importe quelle sorte
de jazz pour le plaisir de jouer avec
eux il ne reste plus qu'à les écouter
alors nous espère j'espère que ça leur
va plaire à tout le monde parce que moi
personnellement j'ai prendre grande joie
aller voir étudiées
ah ah
beaucoup
on a maintenant
m
mais
là
il
à
où
quoi